forza horizon 5 has officially been
revealed during microsoft's e3 showcase
and there is a lot to unpack
without exaggeration verizon 5 is
looking like it's going to be the
biggest horizon game so far
what's up all i'm david and i've been
following the news surrounding forza
horizon 5
and just losing it from a completely new
location to a bunch of new gameplay
modes here's why you should get hyped
for forza horizon 5
and what you need to know if you want
more forza horizon 5
then leave us a like and be sure to hit
that bell button and subscribe as well
it's free let's dive in the biggest
reason i'm hyped is forza horizon 5's
location
in this game we're gonna go to beautiful
mexico which creative director mike
brown claims is the largest and most
diverse horizon location in series
history
what is meant by this is that nothing
ever grows stale thanks to the wide
variety of locations offered by mexico
and past forza games notably horizon 4
we were introduced to the concept of
seasons and weather changes distinctly
affecting the way that your car
interacted with the world and location
around you
however severe changes in passports and
games were relegated to dlc drops
such as storm island or blizzard
mountain now this time around horizon 5
looks like it's got everything inside
from the get-go with no two locations
fitting the same aesthetic
the variety is incredible and the
contrast between areas
absolutely striking this isn't the
mexico that players might have imagined
when you consider all the different
aspects of it
living deserts beautiful beaches huge
canyons
lush jungles and a massive massive
snow-capped volcano which is also
the highest point in a horizon game ever
the seasonal system returns in horizon 5
and it works on a weekly cadence but
there's even more added to the dynamic
weather system
forza horizon 5 marks all new types of
weather events such as huge dust
tornadoes and even tropical storms
now the xbox e3 showcase had a developer
deep dive that showed clear respect to
the land by playground games
the dev stated that they scaled and
rendered the area with the desire to
keep the recreation of mexico
one that is authentic honest and clearly
filled with love
the faithful adaptation from the preview
footage looks amazing and it makes the
anticipation of the rest of the game
much greater
now we have the awesome graphics 4k is
the way these days
and although more technical gamers might
not be totally satisfied with the 30fps
cap and horizon 5 console's graphics
mode
but the xbox series x will have a
performance mode that allows up to 60
fps
the series s will be locked at 30 fps at
1080p but will also have a 60fps
performance option
now this doesn't mean that the game
won't look great visually warsaw horizon
5 is confirmed to have ray tracing
before zavista
meaning that the lighting rendered in
the game is absolutely stunning when
you're checking out your car
now ray tracing might not make it out to
the rest of the game however
playground games even capture the mexico
sky in 12k
with an hdr camera rig so in normal
speak this means that the sky that you
see in the game
looks real that lighting is truly
one-to-one
and dynamic creating a lifelike visual
experience
sharper details like that of the volcano
were captured in real life on location
as well
and the level of detail means that even
needles on a cactus
are individually considered now with all
the visual fidelity aside
forza horizon 5 is also bringing a
flurry of changes to gameplay modes
for starters there is an all new
campaign taking players through each
area of mexico as you partake in races
various adventures and horizon festival
showcases where you get to meet new
characters across
dozens of missions and expeditions i'm
racing a car through the mexican jungle
rami
doesn't get much better than this the
live service makes its way into a new
generation as well with the fantastic
addition and online play
the drivers that you will see in the
world can be all real players online
and the experience is enhanced with the
all-new forza link
now forza link is the ai that
intelligently interacts on your behalf
with the game world
through it you can set markers on the
gps communicate with nearby drivers
and even challenge them to erase all on
the go while you're exploring the
environment
even more impressive is that forza link
can study the data of each driver
and give suggestions based on what it
knows about your driving habits and
those of the players around you
in one example they show that a player
has an affinity for the arcade minigames
and suggests to the main player to
specifically invite them to play those
minigames
creating a greater chance that the
matchmaking requests will be accepted
the standout feature for me when it
comes to gameplay modes
is the chance it offers for players to
create entertaining original arcade
minigames of their own
through the brand new events lab this
completely new tool set allows players
to create their own game modes
races and mini games you can customize
everything
including the rules and events lab is
based on playground game's own internal
design tools
and has been repackaged and fit to be
digestible for regular players but don't
think that events lab is limited in
possibility
not only can you just set up your own
mini games but you can even alter the
physics of the game like making the cars
heavier
or reduce the gravity the customization
is expected to be
deep and that is really exciting lastly
we have horizon
open and tour both attempting to
redefine the traditional experiences in
pve and pvp in an open world
for horizon open you are allowed to
seamlessly jump into sessions with other
drivers for all things racing
games the battle royale mode eliminator
from forza horizon 4
and so much more without any pressure to
linger in the session
allowing you to stay for as long as you
like horizon tour also lets players jump
into races against average difficulty
drivatars
to capture all the aesthetic of a
regular car meet where players meet up
in the world to race
and have options to continue together to
the next tour location as well
now microsoft has pledged that all first
party games would get the red carpet
treatment when it comes to convenience
for gamers and forza horizon 5
is no exception crossplay and cross save
will both be available
and forza horizon 5 will also be
available on day one on xbox game pass
for the standard digital edition
seeing forza horizon 5 triumphantly give
that green light to all of this
might be one of the biggest reasons for
me to get absolutely psyched
there is so much to digest with this
game and what it offers and
everything from mexico's stunning
landscape to the redefined gameplay
modes
is sure to set forza horizon 5 apart
from its predecessors
in a fun new way let us know in the
comments if you are all so excited and
why
because i'd love to hear your thoughts
thanks for watching
[Music]
you